hey guys pete here today i'm going to
talk about better call saul season 6
episode 3. rockin hard place was a heavy
episode where everything happened just
how it had to but even knowing 100 that
it couldn't turn out differently based
on the characters that were involved i
was still breathless on the edge of my
seat hoping there might be a way it was
brutal it was beautiful it gave us a
world-class performance and it leaves
you with a feeling that's hard to shake
i'll recap everything that happened and
let you know what i thought about it
right after this quick spoiler warning
if you haven't watched the third episode
of better call saul's sixth season then
this video won't be for you and with
that out of the way let's get into it
the episode opens with a teaser that's
set in the desert you see that there's a
storm approaching above and the camera
moves over the ground until it finds its
way to a blue flower that it focuses on
the rain starts to fall as you notice a
piece of broken glass that tells you
that something has happened here after
the opening credits we catch back up
with nacho who we last saw fleeing the
motel's parking lot in a shot up truck
that didn't get him very far he leaves
that behind he runs into a nearby field
and comes across an old tanker and with
no other options he decides to get
inside luckily there's still a bit of
oil inside so he's able to submerge
himself and he manages to hold his
breath long enough to wait out the
initial search this is a great visual
representation of what nacho is going
through at the moment but also what he's
been dealing with for the last several
seasons the thought of being covered
with oil it's the kind of thing where
you can't just wash that off and it's
like a reflection of his inability to
get out of the game or convince his
father that they need to run away the
decisions he made before got him into
this desperate situation and now here he
is he has no shelter no place to hide no
phone no food no one to trust he knows
that everyone on both sides wants him
dead and all he can do is wait inside a
can covered with sludge
after dark he makes his way to an auto
mechanic shop to try to rinse himself
off this turns out to be his one break
because the middle-aged man that's there
doesn't want to get involved he lets him
stay there without asking any questions
he uses his phone and the first call he
wants to make is to his father there
isn't much hope here he says i just
wanted to hear your voice and you
believe him there's nothing either one
of these men can say to each other to
change the reality of what's happening
his father doesn't know the specifics
but he knows enough to understand that
things will never be right unless nacho
gets himself out of this situation he
offers the only advice that makes sense
from his perspective he tells him to go
to the police one more time nacho knows
this isn't an option and by now that
there's no escape so what else is there
left to say they say goodbye and the
gravity of things really starts to set
in this is tragic because it always
seemed like nacho tried to protect his
father in relation to how dangerous his
situation was he knew the only way they
could get out would be to run together
and his father wouldn't go for that he
never really presented it in that way he
never put that on him and instead tried
to handle things himself which is what
got him to where he's at in this moment
this call is just a step in accepting
the sacrifice he knows he has to make to
protect the thing he cares about the
most then he makes the call that we saw
from the other side in episode two this
time we hear what he's saying to mike
and the proposal that he makes to gus
he'll come back and forfeit his life in
exchange for his father getting away
free and clear a little while later in
the warehouse you see how he gets back
into the country mike pulls him out of a
truck he gives him some takeout food and
while he's eating he learns that his
life will end tomorrow they leave it
there and then victor comes down the
stairs nacho learns that he looks too
pretty to give up his life for gus's
failed attempt on lalos mike agrees to
take care of it and then he pulls out a
bottle to share a lash drink with what
is essentially a dead man walking what
we know has to happen is inevitable the
choices that set things in motion were
made a long time ago these are two
people playing the cards they were dealt
and time is running out for one of them
when gus arrives at the chicken farm to
brief the freshly roughed up nacho you
get the idea of how things are supposed
to play out he needs to confess his
involvement with alvarez and the
peruvians to balsa but then make a run
for it so that victor can kill him
before he's handed over to the
salamancas which will deprive them of
their chance to kill him slow it's a
small consideration but it's not nothing
because i don't even want to think about
what they might have done if they were
given the chance
outside mike lobbies gus to let him be
there for insurance not right there but
nearby and that leaves nacho by himself
where we see him pour a glass of water
and then notice that the glass that gus
broke is still in the garbage can the
next morning they drop mike off on the
approach to the meeting and keeping with
the inevitability of it all and there
not being anything left to say they just
nod to each other as a goodbye you see
that mike takes up a position to watch
how things play out on the same ridge
where he was going to kill hector back
in the season 2 finale when tyrus tells
nacho to turn around so he can put on
the zip tie you see that he's palmed a
piece of glass that he got from gus's
trailer and that we saw on the ground in
the opening teaser scene the van arrives
bolsa the cousins and hector are all
waiting they bring him out and he tells
him today you're gonna die but there are
good deaths and there are bad deaths and
he gives him a chance to come clean
about who hired him as he's telling him
that you can see the torture implements
waiting for him inside nacho delivers
what he's supposed to say he fulfills
his obligation to gus and knows that
mike has pledged to protect his father
and then he takes the opportunity to end
things on his terms he tells them that
he was being paid for years but he would
have done it for free he lets the
salamancas know what he thinks of them
and then tells hector that he's the one
that put him in that wheelchair he uses
the piece of glass to get out of the zip
tie grabs bolsa's gun and lets the fear
of what might happen next sink in for a
moment and then he turns it on himself
to end his life his way it was rough but
a great ending for an amazing character
one that will certainly be missed this
is one of those situations where you
know how it's going to play out because
these other characters we know how their
stories end and it still managed to be
intense he wanted it to turn out
differently but he managed to make it a
good death the best possible death he
could hope for at that point and if i
ever find myself sucking down jello i
will think a nacho and i will come back
around to talk about this more at the
end
i broke things up this way because i
figured nacho's ending was in the front
of everyone's minds but also because
looking at that looking at what he was
up against it kind of puts kim and
jimmy's plans into perspective and where
it was nacho who saw what jimmy couldn't
back when they first met in season one
this time it's hule that points it out
we find jimmy at home taking a painting
down from the wall this is the same
painting we saw coming down the stairs
in the episode one teaser that i
mentioned in my golden toilet video and
we see here how it holds some
significance in that pre-easter egg
category that peter gould was talking
about on the back there are a number of
post-it notes laying out their plan for
taking down howard some of them look
familiar there's a carrot and one for
the tour of the country club and then
there are some others saying things like
costume tuesday nine a phone call
casting and jay stengel he moves one
that says paint and replaces it with one
that says namaste which is referring to
howard's license plate from their
conversation you pick up that they were
planning on getting a copy of howard's
car to use in their plan but they're
running out of time in the first of our
reminders that kim is the one who is way
more pumped up about this plan she
throws out the idea of using his real
car as in stealing howard's car jimmy is
quick to point out the risks that that
would involve but then he reconsiders he
brings up something called the ballet
scam and says it has huel's name written
all over it the idea of pulling a scam
like this off turns things around for
him and you can see that kim responds to
the spark when she kisses him but so far
i still think he's more going along with
things rather than being fully committed
when they get to the courthouse she
passes off a file on one of her clients
to ada ericsson who's surprised by the
gesture because it's something they
would have never come up with on their
own she thinks about that and then she
calls after kim to tell her she has
something she wants to show her in her
office she lays out the jorge de guzman
file and tells her she knows that this
is really lalo salamanca this has all
come to light because he was killed in a
massive fire fight at his compound kim
does a good job of acting surprised
about the revelation and wants to know
why she's telling her about it they go
back and forth kim reminds her that she
called jimmy a scumbag and eriksen
admits that she has problems with saul
but she also believes underneath it all
underneath all this showiness he's a
lawyer and a human being and she thinks
he knows what's right she just described
the character in a nutshell which shows
she has some pretty good instincts only
here she's coming to kim because she
thinks she's the more reasonable of the
two which isn't exactly clear at this
particular moment in the story lalo
being dead is actually good news but it
also brings the situation back up when
kim has been so tightly focused on
howard you see his car pull up at the
valet at fork a real creature of habit
this guy as the attendant does his job
you see hull's plan unfold in a bump
that resembles the beginning of the end
of another mcgill he gets a hold of the
keys his guy has to act fast to cut a
copy of the key and spoof the electronic
fob it's thrilling to watch as the
attendant rushes back to the car but as
you might guess it all works out in the
end he passes off the device to jimmy
and gets his payment and before he
leaves he asks if he can ask him a
personal question he can't understand
why jimmy and his wife with their legit
jobs were they do just fine making legit
money would go out and do something like
this jimmy thinks he isn't able to see
the bigger picture he knows this looks
just like a normal scam but says what
they're doing is going to improve a lot
of people's lives it's the story they
tell themselves but it also feels like
he's trying to convince himself as much
as he's trying to convince the
pickpocket in his passenger seat huel
says if you say so and the look on his
face here mirrors the one that he makes
at the end of the next scene there kim
is waiting at home smoking and looking
at the sticky notes when he comes in he
tells her he'll came through now they
have a key they can unlock and take
howard's car and she tells him about her
conversation with eriksen she lays it
out that jimmy could break
confidentiality and help them with their
case and he asked him what she thinks he
should do that's somewhat surprising and
i feel like it's another reminder that
he's not completely recovered yet but
kim's answer is what really blows your
mind like she's done so many times in
this series she tells him he can make
his own decision but she explains the
situation as him having a choice of
being a friend of the cartel or a rat
which of course there is some truth to
that he would have to look over his
shoulder even if the ada kept her word
and kept his involvement out of it but
if you think back to like season two you
would never imagine these words coming
out of kim's mouth and the way she's
presenting it she's not really giving
him a choice and that's where things are
left with them
so wow we're only at episode three and
one of the series big mysteries what
would happen to nacho has been addressed
we got what i think was a very good
ending but certainly not a happy one i
mentioned in the live stream we did last
week that i couldn't imagine a way he
could get out of this so i knew on some
level that this was probably coming but
seeing it play out is a different thing
altogether i suppose the other side of
things here is a little less exciting
but there were some interesting bits to
ponder with what's happening between
jimmy and kim and i believe it made
sense to make this episode mostly about
nacho his situation is really extreme
but i also find it relatable in a
detached kind of way which adds to the
connection to the character and man you
have to give it to michael mando he
really brought it in this episode i
think he's always been fantastic he
seems to always come through no matter
what they give him and here he just
solidifies his place as one of the
better characters in any tv show over
the last 10 years if you think about the
chain of events that happened to get all
those characters in that same place gus
was involved with something in chile but
manages to make it out he tries to
connect with the cartel and hector kills
max on their behalf to teach him a
lesson nacho gets involved with the
salamancas he brings mike in to take
care of tuko after he becomes a problem
that has mike end up going after hector
because of the good samaritan gus
intervenes there because he doesn't want
that to happen nacho tries to kill
hector gus intervenes again so that he
can torture him while using that
knowledge to control nacho then he
involves him in his plan to try to kill
lalo and here we are with nacho giving
up his life to try to protect his father
the one innocent man in this entire
equation nacho as a character was born
from jimmy's throwaway line in the
desert and they managed to turn that
into something i'm not sure that i can
get from where we're at to jimmy
bringing up his name in the desert yet i
think there might be more that has to
happen i mean obviously something will
happen with lalo and i think there
should be a reason why he says ignacio
in that scene but as far as who he
became everything that led up to this
final scene made sense i didn't want to
see him go but i liked that he knew that
mike would protect his father that's a
major accomplishment considering what he
was up against at the beginning of this
episode and as i mentioned before he did
manage to go out on his own terms after
the last episode i was wondering how
they were going to deal with the idea
that hector knows that lalo's still
alive and is thinking that gus tried to
kill him i mean correctly of course but
that wouldn't have made a lot of sense
considering things that we saw later in
the story it felt like at some time that
might blow up in his face in relation to
the cartel if hector knew that i think
the way that it played out here nacho
was able to sell the idea that gus
really wasn't involved with what
happened he turned it all on himself and
it was so satisfying to see him turn
things around on the salamancas before
he took himself out snatching their
chance to make him pay right out from
under them and then having the cousins
carry hector over to fire rounds into
his dead body was the perfect way to
show that he won and he still managed to
hold on to his honor in a sort of
sideways fashion in the strange world
they inhabit it's interesting to think
of mike's journey in relation to nacho
as well mike's been on his descent and
nacho reached out to him when he was
first trying to think about how to get
out of the life mike wouldn't kill
anyone at that time in the game or not
and we've been watching how his code has
been changing nacho never really became
something else or at least he could
never get away either so this bond they
have even in this dark chapter is kind
of fascinating at a time they were kind
of moving in different directions both
of them trying to be better but they
still ended up here despite those
efforts on the other side kim is focused
and jimmy's a little harder to pin down
it's still feeling quite difficult to
understand why they think they can just
keep doing this kind of stuff without
howard figuring out it's them that's
doing it i mean they're stealing his car
that's set up now they have the spoofed
device they're gonna be able to take it
how do they get him to not know it was
them unless it is all part of their plan
and then that's where things will get
interesting i really like what they did
with huel here and i like the way that
they had ericsson point out what we know
to be true about jimmy and even offer a
path that might pull him back on the
right side of things but then just have
kim shoot that down obviously jimmy is
afraid of the cartel and he's not going
to choose the path of the rat i mean it
probably would be ill-advised either way
but the offer being there serves as a
reminder for kim and for us that saul is
drifting farther away from the jimmy we
met in season one and i think that's a
good place to leave things i'll
definitely be making some more better
call saul videos this week so let me
know in the comments what you think
about what happened how you think they
handled closing out nacho's story what
you think is gonna happen next please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon